i had a purpose
i wanted to be one of the best
basketball players i ever play and
anything else that was outside of that
lane
i didn't have time for
[Music]
the love of the game the challenge like
i would watch magic play i'd watch
michael play
and i would see them do these
unbelievable things and i said you know
can i get to that level
i don't know but let's find out and so
that curiosity to see
where i could push this thing let me
down that path i think
[Music]
everything was done to try to learn how
to become a better basketball player
everything everything and so when you
have that point of view
then literally the world becomes your
library
to help you to become better at your
craft
i bought into the meditation i bought
into the deeper
connection that exists within the game
and so when you watch our teams or you
watch any of phil's teams or chicago
teams
game six against utah you watch our
games
you know game seven against boston we
were never rattled
ever because we're always in the moment
always in the present
always extremely calm always looking at
the reality of the situation
and not letting our emotions cloud our
execution
and that comes from being in that
meditative state that he would teach and
preach from day one
but it's a balancing act and that's the
thing that's important is understanding
that we have to have
so much energy because for like natalia
and gianna when they were babies
especially natalia because they was
doing prime years
and i go to practice and i i'd train and
you know i'd play the game and
i'd come home and i'd be sore and i'd be
tired
and she wants to go swimming she wants
me to take her to the park
she wants to just jump on my back or
whatever the case may be
you can't say i'm too tired i'm going to
lay down
that's not fair she don't know what the
hell is going on
right and if this was a game you'd suck
it up and play
i play games with the flu i play games
with 102 degree fever man
you can't do that it's all powerful
as a parent you got to set the example
you got to set the example this
this is another obstacle this obstacle
cannot define me
it's not going to [ __ ] me it's not
going to be responsible
for me stepping away for the game that i
love i'm going to step away
on my own terms yeah you got to lead by
example
as parents you got to lead by example if
you want your kids to do
whatever it is they want to accomplish
in life you have to show them
you can't
[Music]
you